- Air plants.
Airhead.
Education.
Hello, and welcome to FriDiary.
For all of yous that don't...
for all of yous that don't know, so close.
For all of you that do not know,
FriDiary is a look back at my week
in Vlog form and because we had
an extra video, an extra video,
because we announced the movie last week,
I didn't put up FriDiary last week.
So, this is two weeks compilated together.
Compilated is a word?
They're not arguing it, so...
So, here are some of things that
have happened to me
over the last two weeks.
This happened,
Hello FriDiary, it is Saturday
and we are headed (singing) downtown.
Literally, we are going downtown to L.A.
and we are going to shoot a sketch
with Anna Akana!
I'm very excited because she doesn't
half-ass a sketch.
Here's a spoiler, I had to get fitted
for a bodysuit for this sketch,
so it's going to be fan (cymbal) tastic!
And, I'm really excited to work with her.
She was on the podcast a few weeks ago.
Listen to the episode, if you have it.
And she's just funny and smart.
What an excellent combo.
Let's go shoot some funny,
smart stuff with her.
Yay!
(Circle of Life intro plays)
And then, this happened,
Hi, FriDiary, it is Sunday night,
I am watching some Lilly Singh Vlogs.
And, I have a lot of work to do,
so, of course, I decided
to paint this room.
Green has always bothered me
because it's a little too bright
and the rest of the house is really
like neutral, calm colors.
So, I'm painting it this light blue
which might end up being
a primer for another color,
but it's happening, it's like 11 p.m.
Oh, by the time this
video goes up you'll know.
So, tomorrow morning, Monday,
Mamrie, Hannah, and I start
rehearsals for Dirty Thirty,
the new film that we are doing
which is super exciting,
and also very nerve-wrecking.
So, I went for a jog and now I'm painting.
A lot of other things, I should be doing
but this is very therapeutic.
Lord knows, I could use all the
therapy I could get.
(salsa music)
Are you excited?
- [Mamrie] (singing) And cooking.
Oh my God, look at these two idiots.
- [Man] I told you she
didn't see you do the bit.
- [Grace] I missed a bit
already? Look at this.
- [Man] Yeah, it was a
really horrible bit.
- [Mamrie] Was a quality bit.
- It was about an exclusive.
- [Grace] I was still
smash-mouthed all morning.
(laughing)
- [Man] It's horrible. It's horrible.
You probably don't want to waste
your digital camera.
(laughing)
- [Grace] This is very telling.
Script title, written
by name of first writer.
Based on, if any.
Yes, this is how rehearsal happens.
- [Mamrie] This is where I live now
because I can't move.
(laughter)
- [Man] Grace, this is you.
- [Mamrie] Hey guys, normal day.
- [Man] This is you.
- [Mamrie] Look at the
life of glamour we lead.
- [Grace] I know, it's really nice.
And then, this happened,
(cuban music)
- [Chester] I got sour punch kids,
sour patch kids.
I called them sour punch, what a loser.
I got a cookie.
- [Grace] Oh, that's your business card?
- [Chester] And then, I've got popcorn,
diet coke, and a good attitude.
Oh, all the food groups.
All ingredients to enjoy a film.
- Here's something,
Yes, Goose. Bring it home to victory.
You are a metaphor for my life, Goose.
- [Voiceover] What is this?
- [Grace] You did it!
You got it all the way home.
Are you so happy that you've ripped up
this entire branch in the living room?
- [Voiceover] You do it, Goose?
- Then went to New York
City for Stream-Con.
(cuban music)
Thank you very much.
Apparently this is how we're rolling
to Stream-Con today. God bless.
(cuban music)
- [Voiceover] He's a day maker.
- [Mamrie] It's Doug the pug.
Oh my god.
- [Woman] He's purring.
- [Voiceover] You're cooler than
I'll ever be in my entire life.
Oh my gosh, Doug and Beanz need to collab.
- [Grace] Don't mind this,
just my parents getting out of a limo.
- [Dad] Oh, yes.
Here in New York City.
And so my family experienced cold,
I came back and then this happened,
(cuban music)
Hello FriDiary, it is Wednesday.
I did not film much at the beginning
of this week because sometimes you need
to take mental health days.
That's what I've realized, and it's okay.
I am leaving my first fitting
for Dirty Thirty.
Whoo, whoo, whoo!
Very exciting.
I have suitcases because I brought
all of my clothes, too,
to contribute since we,
this thing's low budget, guys.
Just keep that in mind,
low budget, big hearts.
Can't lose, subscribers.
Because you can't subscribe to the movie.
Yes, you can.
Dirty Thirty movie dot com.
And now, I'm going home.
Great update. Gotta go.
And then this happened,
(singing) I'm sweaty.
Hello, FriDiary.
By now you know that Trivy,
the trivia app launched by Chester See
and Rhett and Link is available
in the app store if you like trivia games
and you like youtubers.
it's a really awesome trivia app that
is not only a general trivia game
but they are, I think,
over 60 expansion packs
geared towards trivia about a specific
youtuber that you could download
which is so exciting.
It's currently Wednesday night, right,
Wednesday afternoon and tonight
at midnight, it launches.
Here's hoping that when
this video goes live,
it has done well and you
guys are enjoying it,
but in celebration of it launching,
I just went to Michael's Crafts
and I bought so many things.
And, I bought Sephora makeup for myself,
but I bought all of these crafts to try
and decorate the house like the game,
and make cake,
like try to make fancy, exciting cake.
I don't know why I wanted to do that,
but I wanted to do that.
So, we're gonna do that in launch of Trivy
and Chester See, Whoo!
So, we're gonna...
Let's start decorating.
This is the before.
(chiming)
Okay.
(Circle of Life intro music)
And, this is the after.
It is 9:20 p.m. right now.
There are some decorations,
hashtag Trivy sign that I made,
some gifts, some general color scheme.
Oh more general color scheme.
Whaaa....
And, this might be the best part.
I made a cake.
Well, I made a cake
and it has a specific message
to the competitors of Trivy.
J/K, J/K, Quiz Up, you're a great app.
So, Chester should be back in a second.
YAY!
Goosie's so excited.
Oh, yeah. Goose is wearing,
she's wearing a shirt that
is appropriate for the occasion.
You'll probably see it.
Good morning, FriDiary.
It is Thursday and Trivy has launched!
- Trivy has launched.
- YAY!
And, it seems like you guys really like it
and that's so exciting.
- I hope so.
- Yeah. This has been a
long work in progress,
so it's so fun that you guys get
to share in it now, woohoo!
If you haven't already,
go to the app store and download
Trivy, the trivia app.
And, to celebrate Trivy being out,
we're gonna go get burritos!
- Breakfast burritos.
- Breakfast burritos!
- [Voiceover] Look at this.
- My grape soda is sticky!
- [Voiceover] I had a
joke and you ruined it.
Take two.
- You laughed last time I said that.
- [Voiceover] I know, but, cause you said,
this time in the middle
of my trying to do a joke.
Okay, take two.
Pretend you didn't see that FriDiary.
Look at this beautiful...
burrito.
(audience laughter)
- Burrito monster.
- [Grace] She doesn't get it.
(laughing)
(Circle of Life intro music)
- Oh. More secrets.
And now, it is actually Friday.
I woke up this morning and wanted
to make jewelry.
Look, can you read what it says?
I'm working on it.
It's the first one.
It says statement.
It's a statement necklace.
Get it?
I made it.
There's a lot of things
happening right now.
On Monday, we actually start
production for Dirty Thirty.
We start shooting on Monday
which is bonkers and
I'm nervous and excited.
Goose is making every possible noise.
That happens Monday.
Let's see, Oh, Hannah, Mamrie, and I
announced that we are going to Australia
this December with the No Filter show,
so there's a link in the description.
Get your tickets, please.
We're only doing a couple of shows
and we, I've never been to Australia.
It's a long trek to get there,
so I don't think we're gonna
be back any time soon.
And, these shows are
selling out very quickly
so please, please, please
get your tickets asap
if you really want to be...
there.
What else is there?
Trivy launched! Yay!
That's there, go get
that, if you like that.
Also, I'm nominated for
a People's Choice Award
for Youtuber, cool
Youtuber-ish kind of thing,
among a bunch of really
great other Youtubers.
I think it's Miranda Sings, Tyler Oakley,
Jenna Marbles, Connor Franta, I think,
but the link to vote is down there
because you people choose the awards,
People's Choice Awards.
If you wanna vote for any
of those human beings,
myself included, go down there and vote.
Because that's cool.
Oh, book. Ahh!
So, my second book,
Grace & Style: The Art
of Pretending You Have It
is just about completely done
and I am so excited about it.
It comes out February 2nd.
If you want to pre-order it now, you can.
The link is down below,
and I'm thinking every Friday on FriDiary,
I'm gonna have a little
book bonus section,
some quick snippet to talk to you guys
about the book.
I also wanna do a couple live streams
this month where I get to talk
to you guys in real time about the book
because it was meant to be something
really, kind of, surface
and silly and stupid,
and it has all of those qualities,
but it ended up being something
really personal too,
and really...
that.
Yeah, it's that.
So I'm really excited and nervous
about it, in a good way.
I guess, I won't start
book bonus this week
but I want to start them next week
so leave me some questions you might have
about the book in com- (coughs)
devil's trying to get out of me.
Leave me some questions in the
comments section that you might have
about the book that I can
speak about next week.
And, I'm just so excited about it.
So, go pre-order the book now
if you like things like that.
I think that's all of
the plugs that I have.
I need an extension cord because
I have used all of your outlets.
I'm so sorry.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know what Starbucks red cups are.
I thought pumpkin spice
lattes were the only
thing that we celebrated
from Starbucks in the fall.
I'm speaking in the collective we,
like it's some religion.
I don't know what red cups are.
It's their holiday cups and it makes
coffee taste different, question mark.
Sincere question.
Girls, all my social media seem to care
about red cups so much that I made a joke,
how do we combine birth
control and red cups
because the care that
women have for red cups
and the importance that birth control has,
if we just combine them, life would be
so much easier for ladies.
Many of you guys are
like, "Go to sleep, Grace.
"Are you drunk?"
Sleep. What? Okay. Huh?
"I'd lay off the coke right about now."
(boing)
Smiley face.
Guys, give me half a chance.
Darron Diesel says "Is red
cups and birth control,
"the new Netflix and chill?"
I hope so.